here's wolf from Philadelphia yes Wolfie
hey I was curious to know when JD was
initially hired who was the person that
interviewed him heard his verbal prowess
and decided this is the best candidate
for the job I believe the way JD was
hired JD was an intern here and then JD
was particularly good at getting these
clips together and he sort of formed his
own job he started to take it on on his
own am i right Gary yeah he was a
actually used his head and was a
self-starter that was maybe the only
time he's ever had take as taking some
initiative and I have to say he's
terrific at it he really is really good
and very proud of his job I know what
this guy means Wolfie JD is the kind of
kid he can't imagine being in the room
going yard you know you get scared you
like a Frankenstein monster but could
you imagine if we had JD's and initial
interview so tell me what is it you like
doing your movie director well exactly I
don't know maybe a movie studying film
video this is JD's resume oh gosh let's
see I just like his description of his
prior employment I highlighted it JD you
know Jamie har Meyer okay this is a
dress then he goes related experience
writer and director of film shorts for
Lake Gibson high school TV productions
get those various positions on spelling
witness a 16-millimeter student film
directed a scene instructed actors and
crew oh I'd love to get a paper though
okay look there wasn't much everyone
said and say all right go employment si
si assistant manager
Gallery Lakeland Florida I checked the
movies in and out their customers rented
receive product in the computer system
exported product out of the system help
during inventory cleaned up store made
late calls etc that's good I like that
I had to is my job so I can go oh well I
see here you have related experience
tell me about that
what would you say related experience as
to how the movie gallery work I dealt
with people and I you know it was hot I
was a miracle I mean I have three
standard interview questions is there
any chance I could ask them to JD what
yeah that'd be great
this guy again Jamie tell me about
yourself what I'm like you know I'm nice
I think I have some sort of intelligence
overall intelligence was interviewing
for a job you know I I do have some sort
of people skills whenever whenever I
have to talk to people um that's
fascinating uh where do you see yourself
in five years I I have no idea right now
oh hopefully uh being a director but
we'll see Howard my third question was
what are your weaknesses but I think he
already answered that what are your
weaknesses one of my weaknesses
Venus's weakness I said weaknesses I'm
shy
I don't know weaknesses I realize your
whole job interview lasted like not even
30 seconds well if he asks you three
questions and you
terribly wolfy came up with another
brilliant bit there you go Oh take it
easy these are typical interview
questions well I I if I if I've to do an
interview I will prep myself and get
myself you know ready for an interview
somebody on the air for a caller you I
have a good sense of humor that's a
weakness okay I don't want to do this
again I'm spontaneous spontaneous that's
a weakness I'm sorry
JD's like this tell me about yourself
well on the internet I'm known as the
badass huh all right wolf well that was
very informative thank you okay they're
brilliant bill wolf
hey thanks Eddie I love you [ __ ] off